populaire qui permet d'introduire un
nouvel article de la constitution chute
même que un sujet arrive en votation
signifie qu'il ya un problème
ce qui oblige les partenaires comme dit
qu'à se remettre autour de la table
leicester il faudrait pas y avoir de
dérive populiste vrai que leurs proches
dont le risque de la voir les votations
sur des sujets dits populis mais je
pense malgré tout que le meilleur moyen
pour lutter contre le populisme c'est
précisément d'en discuter et de trancher
[Musique]
à la une la fédération hospitalière
plaide en faveur de la vaccination
obligatoire pour tous actuellement
seules celles des soignants pour est
entrée en vigueur en france
hier plus de deux cent mille
manifestants ont battu le pavé dans
toute la france avec parfois des
tensions et des heurts avec les forces
de l'ordre
[Musique]
ailleurs en europe la grogne contre les
mesures sanitaires également en
allemagne
des échauffourées à berlin lors de
manifestations anti confinement
l'initiative vient du mouvement quad
core ou libres penseurs qui s'est
imposée comme la principale voix
critiques aux restrictions
dans l'actualité également birmanie le
chef de l'armée promet des élections
multipartites et démocratiques d'ici
deux ans voilà six mois que les
militaires ont pris les commandes du
pays destituant 1 c'est au centre succi
à les manifestations se multiplient une
situation qui divise la communauté
internationale
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france l'actualité en
france et la loi sanitaire qui doit
entrer en vigueur elle prévoit entre
autres la vaccination obligatoire des
soignants à la fédération hospitalière
va plus loin elle estime que cette
obligation doit être mise en place pour
tous sans distinction de profession son
président frédéric valletoux l'a fait
savoir dans le jdd
selon lui les indicateurs repartent à la
hausse et nous n'avons plus le luxe de
prendre de demi mesure at il dit on sait
que la vaccination obligatoire pour tous
a déjà été évoqué par emmanuel macron a
dans son discours du 12 juillet par
ailleurs la fédération hospitalière
estime également que le passé ni terre
est un outil dépassez pas suffisant pour
freiner une quatrième vague virulente
pourtant elle c'est ce même pas ce qui a
fait descendre dans les rues de 200000
personnes hier en france touche
mobiliser contre une mesure jugée
liberticide on voit cela avec cyrielle
beau et chiens
une mobilisation nationale contre le
pass sanitaires à paris quatre cortèges
ont défilé parmi lesquelles ad gilet
jaune et florian philippot à la tête du
parti les patriotes
il faut absolument pas que ce pass
sanitaire parce c'est de la
discrimination pure et simple et dans le
pays qui prétend être celui des droits
de l'homme ce pas normal qu'ils aient
des restrictions pour faire la
différence entre des non vaccinés des
vaccinés c'est complètement hallucinant
quand on en est là on se demande après
ce qu'on va être demain moi je travaille
à l'éducation nationale et je suis très
inquiète de ce qu'on va sortir les
gamins qui se font pas vacciner plus les
personnels à qui on va dire au bout de
deux mois bas vous allez voir ailleurs
parce que vous n'êtes pas vacciné
moi je suis vacciné mais j'estime que
c'est mon choix et chacun doit avoir le
choix
si les rassemblements se sont dans la
majorité déroulée dans le calme
quelques échauffourées ont éclaté entre
manifestants et forces de l'ordre
[Musique]
montpellier reims ou encore marseille
pas moins de 180 villes de l'hexagone se
sont mobilisés à toulouse et à nantes
les manifestants ont rythmé la marche
d'un cri commun liberté je suis là parce
qu'il ya des incohérences un incroyable
et tout ces privations de libertés sont
insupportables accepté à vivre
m'empêcher d'aller à la piscine parce
que je ne suis pas vacciné on m'empêche
d'aller danser on m'empêche d'aller dans
l'été après tout ce qui fait d'eux le
bien-être de la vie et ça c'est
inadmissible parce que c'est notre corps
c'est pas une guerre entre les vaccinés
et les non vaccinés qu'on mène à l'heure
actuelle
c'est une guerre pour notre liberté bien
des choses assez grave qui sont en train
d'évoluer de se passer dans le pays
c'est pour ça que je suis là ça fait
plus de 40 ans que suis pas venu
manifester et l'âge pour la première
fois je reviens parce que je suis je
suis un peu effrayé de ce qu'il est en
train de se passer
une mobilisation qui ne semble pas
impressionné le gouvernement ce vendredi
le ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin s'est exprimée en amont des
manifestations je constate à paris comme
ailleurs une mobilisation qu'il faut
relativiser puisque on parle de 150000 à
200000 manifestants si je fais un
parallèle avec les 4 millions de
personnes qui se sont fait vacciner
au lendemain du discours du président on
constate que ces manifestants ne sont
pas majoritaires un mouvement pourtant
compris par une majorité de la
population sortie ce vendredi une étude
de l'institut harris interactive dévoile
que 51% des français comprennent les
revendications des manifestants mais
seulement 40 % d'entre eux soutiennent
le mouvement
en allemagne les personnes hostiles aux
mesures anti qu'ovide ont bravé
l'interdiction de manifester aujourd'hui
ils étaient dans les rues de berlin par
sont elles à la police anti-émeute a été
déployée et des affrontements ont eu
lieu est les manifestants dénoncer les
restrictions sanitaires a imposé par les
autorités dont l'éventualité de
conditionner l'accès à certains lieux à
la vaccination
une mobilisation sur appel du mouvement
quoi dans nos coeurs qui signifie libre
penseur gilbert casasus jeu professeur
d'études européennes est revenue sur les
dessous du mouvement en allemagne et
côté alors aujourd'hui il ya eu 3
environ 1000 manifestera berlin se
souvenir que berlin cogan millions
d'habitants donc c'est relativement peu
important il ya quelques mois il y avait
eu plus de manifestants ce mouvement ne
semble pas prendre de l'ampleur nous
sommes à moins de deux mois des
élections allemandes et je ne pense pas
que ce mouvement dans le cadre de la
politique allemande de la politique
intérieure de la campagne électorale
puisse véritablement joué un grand rôle
d'autant que
beaucoup d'allemands n'apprécie pas
beaucoup ce mouvement et quand on parle
de créatine cas c'est à dire ce qu'ils
pensent pas comme il faut ou à travers
si vous voulez on sait que ces gens là
sont extrêmement minoritaires et qu'il
ya un coût du tout est là aussi il faut
savoir que le parti de l'extrême droite
l'afd en sous main soutient ce mouvement
mais le passé les terres la belgique ne
n'imposera pas le premier ministre belge
estime que le taux vaccinale est
suffisant pour s'en passer alexander de
croo a néanmoins précisé qu'une telle
mesure a du sens pour les grands
événements mais doit rester l temporaire
un avis que partage également gilbert
bejjani les médecins anesthésistes à
bruxelles président de l'association
belge des syndicats médicaux pour lui
c'est la majeure partie de la population
est vacciné il est inutile d'imposer un
passé militaire pour les cafés et les
restaurants l'écoutent avec la
vaccination est une protection la rendre
obligatoire ouvre un vrai débat parce
que la mortalité reste quand même faible
c'est vrai que moi j'ai demandé à mon
entourage de se faire vacciner parce
qu'il ya aussi la morbidité la morbidité
ça veut dire toutes les les
complications dues à la co vite mais qui
ne soient pas des complications
mortelles
que ce soit les séquelles donc à long
terme au niveau digestif au niveau de
l'odorat au niveau cérébral au niveau du
sommeil au niveau de l'humeur donc il ya
énormément de bonnes raisons pour se
faire vacciner
ce n'est pas que la mortalité qui
concernait un parent par ce vaccin et
c'est pour ça que je trouve que c'est
important de se faire vacciner
maintenant c'est une mortalité qui est
qui et qui n'est pas très très élevé il
yad'autres d'autres pathologies
sur la face de cette terre si on
commence à faire impasse sanitaires pour
tous il y aurait peut-être des questions
à se poser
je pense que ce genre de débat doit
avoir lieu je dirais de façon très très
large au parlement et ailleurs et alors
que certains pays durcissent les
restrictions d'autres les assouplissent
c'est le cas du portugal qui lèvres son
couvre feu aujourd'hui grâce à la
vaccination selon les autorités allaient
précision c'est avec alexis caude et
cyril benavides pitbull ans
la vaccination est elle la clé
à en croire antonio costa le premier
ministre portugais
c'est en tout cas une condition
sinequanone à l'assouplissement des
mesures de restriction avec la fin du
couvre-feu le pays entre donc dans sa
première étape d'un plan de
déconfinement en trois phases présenté
par le chef du gouvernement jeudi
dernier je crois que le moment est venu
de passer à une gestion de la pandémie
en fonction du critère essentiel de la
vaccination de masse qui est de nous
prévoyons que d'ici dimanche prochain le
1er août
57 % de la population portugaise sera
entièrement vacciner avec deux doses de
vaccin
12 et lorsque ce seuil sera atteint
nous pourrons faire un pas en avant et
gérer la pandémie en fonction du taux de
vaccination de tâches vu venir
car au cours de cette vague épidémique
il a été montré à quel point la
vaccination a été efficace il y a eu
moins de cas moins d'hospitalisations et
moins de décès nous devons donc
poursuivre cette stratégie pouces qui
outre la levée du couvre-feu
cette première étape du déconfinement
permettent également aux commerces
restaurants et salles de spectacles de
rester ouverts jusqu'à 2 heures du matin
pour le moment le masque en extérieur
lui reste de mise il faudra attendre
septembre prochain et une vaccination
complète d'au moins 70% de la population
pour s'en défaire enfin lorsqu au moins
85% de la population sera vaccinée les
limites de capacité dans les restaurants
et événements seront levés
le gouvernement envisagerait même
ouvrir les bars et discothèques sur
présentation du pass sanitaires mais la
vaccination n'est pas la seule condition
à un assouplissement des restrictions
le premier ministre portugais l'a lui
même concédé l'émergence d'un nouveau
variant pourrait bien retarder voire
mettre un terme aux plans de
déconfinement le pèlerinage du hajj a
pris fin avec pour la deuxième année
consécutive seulement des fidèles
musulmans saoudiens ont résidant en
arabie saoudite les étrangers ne pouvant
pas rentrer dans le pays à cause des
restrictions sanitaires
c'est terminé depuis aujourd'hui les
voyageurs sont maintenant autorisés à
entrer sur le territoire saoudien
seulement s'ils sont vaccinés et firent
regarder après 17 mois de fermeture du
pays due à la crise sanitaire
l'arabie saoudite rouvre ses frontières
aux touristes vacciner le ministère du
tourisme a annoncé que le royaume
ouvrira ses portes aux touristes
étrangers et lèvera la suspension de
l'entrée pour les détenteurs de visas
touristiques à partir du 1er août
quatre vaccins sont approuvés par le
royaume
de plus un test pcr négatif de -2 72
heures est exigé pour éviter une
quarantaine l'épidémie de kovy de 19
avait également perturbé les pèlerinage
des musulmans du monde entier
seuls les saoudiens et étrangers
vacciner résidant dans le pays peuvent
encore s'y rendre il grâce à dieu nous
avons obtenu l'autorisation d'effectuer
le hajj même si on ne s'attendait pas à
être acceptés en raison du nombre limité
de pèlerins a accepté et comme vous
pouvez le constater le gouvernement
saoudien fait de son mieux
tout est bien organisé
l'arabie saoudite a recensé plus d'un
demi million de cas et a dépassé la
barre des 8000 morts liés aux cowboys 19
aujourd'hui environ 23% de la population
saoudienne est complètement vaccinés à
compter du 1er août
la vaccination sera obligatoire dans les
centres commerciaux les établissements
scolaires ou encore les transports en
birmanie cela fait six mois aujourd'hui
que la junte a pris le pouvoir et le
chef de l'armée a profité de cette
occasion pour annoncer l'organisation
d'élections générales multipartites et
démocratique dit fear 2 en écoute et
nous prendrons six mois pour préparer
les élections conformément à la loi nous
accomplirons les dispositions de l'état
d'urgence d'ici août 2000 23
nous devons créer les conditions
favorables à l'organisation d'élections
générales multipartites libres et
équitables
nous devons faire des préparatifs je
m'engage à organiser des élections
générales multipartites sans faille ce
futur scrutin permettra-t-il de sortir
le pays de la crise depuis la prise de
pouvoir par l'armée les birmans ils
manifestent certains fuient le pays et
le co vide 1-1 n'arrange rien on voit
cela avec yamina benguigui
des torches à la main pour exprimer leur
colère six mois après le coup d'état
militaire qui a renversé le gouvernement
danks englouti les manifestations
continuent en birmanie en première ligne
de contestation la génération z celle
des moines de 25 ans mais avec la
révolution numérique
pour eux la junte n'est pas capable
d'affronter de mettre un terme à la
crise économique et sociale que traverse
le pays
quand on observe la situation sociale
économique et politique le gouvernement
militaire n'est pas capable de bien
gérer ces secteurs et en aucun cas nous
ne pouvons accepter de toujours faire
profil bas avec la junte
les contestataires adopte donc une
stratégie à tâtons en organisant des
manifestations sporadiques
histoire de rappeler que la rue n'est
pas disposé à baisser les bras
nous avons peur mais il ya de la colère
derrière cette peur cette colère donne
de l'élan à notre révolution
donc si vous vous demandez si notre
révolution recul nous vous répondons que
nous ne céderons pas pour autant et si
nous reculons c'est parce que nous
faisons seulement un pas en arrière pour
faire ensuite deux pas en avant et nous
en sommes arrivés à cette révolution
parce qu'ils nous ont opprimé un peu
plus une résistance amoindri par la
pandémie de couronnes à virus car le
pays est véritablement submergé par le
cos vite 19 manque d'oxygène de tests de
vaccins une situation sanitaire qui
inquiète la pandémie actuelle a vraiment
mis en pause la résistance et a
définitivement changé la façon dont
cette résistance se manifeste j'entends
par là que les gens sont actuellement
bien plus préoccupés par le cos vie de
10,9 de nombreuses personnes à qui j'ai
parlé m'ont dit qu'elle préférait mourir
plutôt que d'obtenir une assistance
médicale de la part de quiconque est
associée de près ou de loin à l'armée et
c'est très inquiétant car il s'agit
évidemment de la même réaction du public
à l'égard des vaccins
de son côté l'onu tire la sonnette
d'alarmé et accuse des militaires
d'utiliser le coc u19 comme une arme
contre la population
alors que la nouvelle vague de kovy 19
se répand comme une traînée de poudre à
travers le pays
il est malheureux que davantage de vies
soient perdues au moment où l'armée
birmane utilise le coc vite 19 comme
arme contre la population
jeudi le royaume uni a pressé le conseil
de l'onu d'exiger des cessez le feu dans
le pays pour permettre la livraison de
vaccins contre le coronavirus écouter à
propos de ces annonces d'élections à
venir l'analyse de pierre picard un
géopolitologue spécialiste de la chine
actuellement chef d'une petite fille qui
avait été arrêté il ya six mois le
apparaît type le birmanie à paris comme
étant en position je dirais de force
pour remporter les élections parce
qu'elle est populaire
certainement que c'est le candidat qui
va représenter le plus de stabilité et
de sécurité c'est qu'ils aient le désir
des birmans qui va pour l emporter
mais l'opposition à la junte militaire
est également très divisée comme
d'autres d'autres partis avec de
multiples parties dont on peut imaginer
que le résultat des élections seraient
favorables à l'ancien chef du
gouvernement puisqu'elle était déjà élu
en place et qu'elle connaît les rênes du
pouvoir l'armée afghanes semble opposer
une faible résistance aux talibans ces
derniers profitant du retrait des
troupes étrangères du pays avancent et
prennent le contrôle de vastes pans du
territoire jusqu'ici ruraux a désormais
les insurgés s'attaque aux principales
villes
du pays et rate à l'ouest et kandahar au
sud est les civils fuient les combats
les précisions c'est avec emilie google
un bruit devenus quotidiens pour les
afghans celui des balles qui pleuvent
autour des principales villes du pays
forces gouvernementales et milices d'un
côté taliban de l'autre s'affrontent
depuis plusieurs semaines c'est à herat
dans l'ouest que les combats sont les
plus violents
la menace est élevée dans les provinces
de here at elle demandé kandahar en
particulier à lashkar gah
les ennemis ont effectué quelques
mouvements mais nous sommes déterminés à
repousser d'abord leur attaque puis à
renforcer nos lignes de défense et enfin
à nous préparer à reprendre les
territoires perdus preuve de l'avancée
du mouvement djihadiste dans la ville
les locaux de la mission de l'onu en
afghanistan ont été la cible de tirs de
roquettes
une attaque jugée inadmissible par le
secrétariat général des nations unies
les nations unies ont condamné avec la
plus grande fermeté aujourd'hui l'
attaque contre notre principal complexe
à irat au cours de laquelle un garde de
la police afghane a été tué et deux
autres personnes blessées
aucun membre du personnel des nations
unies n'a été blessé dans cet incident
les attaques contre le personnel civil
et les installations des nations unies
sont interdites par le droit
international et peuvent constituer des
crimes de guerre de violents
affrontements qui touche plusieurs
grandes villes du territoire alors que
les talibans auraient pris le contrôle
de la majorité des zones rurales des
hostilités qui se déroule notamment à
kandahar première conquête du mouvement
djihadiste en 1994
lashkar gah ou encore à calathes dans
cette ville du sud du pays
des tirs de mortier ont ravagé une
partie d'un quartier de la ville tuant
au moins cinq personnes et en blessant
douze autres prises au piège par les
combats dans la région
certains habitants envisagent de fuir à
l'étranger les talibans font ses actes
mais le gouvernement nous fait la même
chose à qui devons nous adresser nos
voix nos voix sont ignorés notre islam
est ignorée nous ne vivons pas en tant
que musulmans nous ne voyons ni sécurité
ni paix si nous quittons le pays pour
n'importe quel autre endroit cela sera
bénéfique
ici notre honneur n'est pas en sécurité
nos soeurs ne sont pas en sécurité et
nos vies non plus prise de court par
l'offensive des talibans
les forces gouvernementales peine à
contenir l'avancée des insurgés
un retour au pouvoir du mouvement
djihadiste vingt ans après qu'il en a
été chassée par l'invasion américaine
pourrait jeter des dizaines de milliers
de réfugiés sur les routes du pays à
venir à cette conférence internationale
sur le liban dans trois jours aux
objectifs du rendez vous organisés par
la france avec l'appui des nations unies
répondre aux besoins de libanais
confrontée à l'une des pires crises
socio-économiques de leur histoire et la
menace de sanctions planent toujours sur
les dirigeants politiques du pays à leur
mésentente n'arrange pas la situation
pire encore aller précision avec amaga
souplesse ce visage pourrait redonner de
l'espoir au liban et rétablir un
semblant de stabilité politique
najib mikati a été chargé lundi dernier
par le président michel aoun de former
un gouvernement après l'échec de ses
deux prédécesseurs
une lourde responsabilité pour cet homme
d'affaires accentuée par la pression des
états unis mardi puis celle de la france
et de l'union européenne ce vendredi la
formation urgente d'un gouvernement
pleinement opérationnel en mesure de
lancer les réformes que la situation
exige et qui conditionne tout est
structurel reste la priorité
la france appelle l'ensemble des
dirigeants libanais à agir en ce sens
est en faveur de l'intérêt général le
plus rapidement possible elle se tient
prête à accroître avec ses partenaires
européens et internationaux les
pressions sur les responsables
politiques libanais pour y parvenir si
aucune sanction n'a encore été mise à
exécution
les vingt-sept dispose désormais du
cadre juridique pour le faire les
personnes jugées responsables du blocage
politique
libanais pourri entre autres être
interdites d'entrée sur le territoire
européen
en avril dernier déjà la france avait
restreint l'accès au territoire français
à certaines figures politiques
libanaises des sanctions qui n'ont pas
eu l'effet escompté face à l'impasse de
la situation politique du pays depuis
presque un an
beyrouth s'enfonce un peu plus chaque
jour dans une crise économique et
financière
les tentatives de sauvetage sont vaines
face à un gouvernement inexistant
le 4 août prochain date du premier
anniversaire de l'explosion du port de
beyrouth
une nouvelle conférence internationale
est organisée à l'initiative d'emmanuel
macron pour soutenir et apporter de
l'aide à la population libanaise
depuis ce drame survenu lors de l'été
2020 l'attitude du président vis-à-vis
du liban a régulièrement été qualifié
d'ingérence notamment par une partie de
la classe politique française
on termine avec la ligier ou de tokyo
les athlètes russes qui sont bel et bien
présents laissant 335 et leurs
performances ne manquent pas mais ils
concourent cette année avec la mention
est refait sur leurs maillots acronyme
du comité olympique russe car la russie
en tant que nation ne figure pas dans la
liste des pays participant à ces jeux
explications avec antoine cléroux pas
besoin d'être un voyant pour prédire que
les performances des athlètes russes au
cours de ces jeux olympiques à l'être
draper d'à priori négatif en effet
permettre aux athlètes russes de
défendre leur chance à tokyo en dépit
d'une suspension de quatre ans pour un
prétendu programme de dopage a créé la
polémique
et pourtant sur la nombre réduit
d'athlète a été autorisé à participer
qui plus est sous bannière neutre ce qui
veut dire sans drapeaux sang hymne pour
des athlètes qui officiellement ne sont
même pas russe et du comité olympique de
russie
par contre ils ont bien eu droit aux
questions impartiale et équilibrée des
journalistes les autres
l'équipe olympique russe porte-t-il les
stigmates des tricheurs dans ces jeux
après le scandale qu'en pensez vous pour
la première fois de ma vie je ne
répondrai pas une question dans une
interview c'est la première fois de ma
vie
vous devriez avoir honte de votre
question je ne veut plus revoir cette
personne en zone mixte de toute la vie
je ne veux pas répondre à ces questions
il faudrait peut-être que vous fassiez
en sorte qu'ils ne soient pas présents
aux jeux olympiques
il semble en effet que la russie profite
d'un traitement de faveur de la part de
la presse en particulier anglo saxon à
croire que tous ces titres on sait que
les athlètes russes n'allait rien
pouvoir faire sans leur dopage
institutionnalisée du côté des athlètes
le fair play et la sportivité ne sont
pas toujours de mise
comme par exemple avec la rameuse
américaine megan calmeau et après s'être
retrouvé derrière la paire russe en
finale du deux sans barreur elle s'est
fendu d'un tweet rageur le fait de voir
une équipe qui ne devrait même pas être
là repartir avec une médaille d'argent
laisse un sentiment désagréable c'est
vraiment décevant d'une manière générale
et j'ai de la peine pour les autres
athlètes de la finale à un autre athlète
américain fait grise mine
le nageur ryan murphy arrivé lors de
deux finales près le russe rilov a
déclaré à chaud que la course n'était
probablement pas propre même s'il s'est
depuis rétractée entre temps un agent
britannique troisième de la course a lui
aussi fait une remarque similaire sur le
dopage
des accusations indirectes ok le comité
olympique russe a tenu à réagir
c'est incroyable de voir à quel point
nos victoires dérange certains de nos
collègues du monde du sport oui nous
sommes là aux jeux olympiques et nous y
avons parfaitement droit que cela leur
plaise ou non il faut savoir perdre mais
ce n'est pas le cas de tout le monde et
on reprend le vieux refrain sur le
dopage russe est quelqu'un essaie de
faire en sorte que cette rengaine ne
s'arrête pas
quoi qu'il en soit les athlètes russes
peuvent compter sur le soutien de tout
un pays mais aussi des autorités
nos athlètes doivent remporter des
médailles de préférence d'or ignorer
tout cela
les médaillés sont au dessus de la
culture je lis et regarde les médias
occidentaux la participation de la
russie aux jo de tokyo les mets tout
simplement hors d'eux tous les irrite
les médailles remportées par nos
athlètes leur uniforme
l'imperturbable it et de l'équipe face à
toutes les intrigues et attaque le
soutien populaire apporté à notre
sélection est désormais aussi les
symboles russe sur les t-shirts des
journalistes j'ai l'impression qu'ils
vont bientôt commencer à envier les
anneaux olympiques sur l'uniforme et le
drapeau de notre équipe nationale
absent des leurs les athlètes russes
invités à participer à ces jeux ont été
triés sur le volet et contrôlée de très
près par les institutions anti dopage
ils le doivent donc leur performance
qu'à eux mêmes
n'en déplaise aux sportifs frustrés et à
la presse rabat-joie effet la fin de ce
journal merci à vous de l'avoir suivi on
va se retrouver dans une trentaine de
minutes rester avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
la grande bretagne a donc eu cinq ans
pour se préparer
cinq ans de psychodrame 50 négociations
politiques
est-ce qu'elle était prête le 31
décembre pour redevenir une île réponse
par du moment où le royaume uni avait
décidé de quitter l'union européenne il
ne pouvait plus continuer de bénéficier
de ses droits équivalents à si vous êtes
dans l'europe et pas dans l'europe
vis-à-vis des 27 états autres c'est
juste quelque chose d'inconcevable
l'angleterre vab à perdre gros là nos
amis britanniques ont fait un choix en
2016 qui est un choix qui je pense va
impacter l'économie profondément sur les
prochaines années et va impacter des
générations les choses sont en train de
se caler de se mettre en place
est ce que les choses sont totalement
fluide réponse est non
[Musique]
le maniement de la rumeur est vieux
comme le monde mais il est vrai que
l'arrivée des réseaux sociaux il va
donner une crédibilité destructrices
dans sa virtualité l'influencent a pris
toute sa place au coeur des
affrontements politiques et économiques
internationaux car elle est une
manifestation de la puissance capable de
peser sur l'évolution des situations
tous les jours nous entendons des
accusations de complotisme contre ceux
qui n'adhèrent pas à la pensée qu'on
dans le fond la théorie du complot
l'explication la plus simple et la plus
facile d'autant qu'elle permet de
désigner un bouc émissaire
évidemment coupable du pire vouloir
forcer le destin en récrivant unis sous